la situation est inédite
jamais l'assemblée nationale n'a connu
une telle configuration sous la vème
république
cette situation constitue un risque pour
notre pays au vu des défis que nous
avons à affronter
tant sur le plan national qu'à l'échelle
internationale
mais ce vote nous devons le respecter et
en tirer les conséquences
en tant que force centrale dans cette
nouvelle assemblée nous devons assumer
une responsabilité particulière
nous travaillerons dès demain à
construire une majorité d'actions
il n'y a pas d'alternative à ce
rassemblement pour garantir à notre pays
la stabilité et conduire les réformes
nécessaires
les sensibilités multiples devront être
associés et les bons compromis bâti afin
d'agir au service de la france
les français nous appelle à nous
rassembler pour le pays
depuis des semaines le gouvernement est
au travail et prend les mesures
nécessaires pour protéger chacun
demain nous devons amplifier et
accélérer notre action au service de
tous les français
dès cet été nous voulons prendre des
mesures fortes et concrètes pour le
pouvoir d'achat
nous voulons continuer à vous protéger
et assurer votre sécurité
au delà je suis certaine que nous
pouvons nous rassembler largement pour
le plein emploi
pour une transition écologique
ambitieuse
pour l'égalité des chances pour l'école
et la santé pour notre souveraineté
industrielles énergétiques et agricoles
avec le président de la république nous
allons oeuvrer dans le dialogue à
l'ecoute des françaises et des français
et de toutes les forces vives partout et
dans tous les territoires
j'ai confiance dans notre pays
confiance en chacun de nous et en notre
esprit de responsabilité
nous avons tout pour réussir et c'est
ensemble que nous y parviendrons
vive la république et vive la france
[Musique]